special edition of PFT p.m. on this
Friday it's a Good Friday edition of the
program and joining us now not a good
tight end or a great tight end the best
tight end in the National Football
League he is 49ers tight end Jorge
Kittel Jorge welcome back how are you
pal hey thanks so much for having man
pleasure to be on hey it's great to talk
to you again so you're in Nashville
right now not in the Bay Area's
Nashville where you're typically
spending your off seasons yes no
Nationals my home I came down here three
years ago CJ Beathard lives here it was
my quarterback at Iowa my quarterback
for the diner so I have someone to throw
to me and then Trent Taylor wide
receiver also lives in Nashville so just
got the teammates down here so it makes
it easy to train
you know not all sports going on right
now but I thought he over the weekend
because I know you're a big wrestling
guy and I saw that Gronk won the 24/7
belt I didn't know what the 24/7 belt
was so I had to look it up apparently
it's something that you have to defend
anywhere any place as long as a WWE
referee is present so if you are ever
around Gronk in the presence of a WWE
referee are you going to try to pin him
yeah I'd have to blindside him though
he's like three inches taller than me
until probably I probably go for the
chop block just take him out the knees
he kind of looks like he's put some
weight back on did you notice that this
weekend yeah that's the thing about John
he always looks like he can play
football so he looked like he always
looks like he's ready to roll but ya
know he looks fabulous he did a great
job on WrestleMania it was just it was
just overall fun to see him out there
having fun and there has been some talk
of grogg possibly coming back to play
with Tom Brady in Tampa Bay pft
commenters dog Leroy had the exclusive
report did this baby have anything to
add one of his jerseys in so Dean he's
not going to break into the the the
canine reporting field is that what
you're telling me no actually right now
she's lying outside in the sunlight
sleeping so she is off of reporting
duties right now what do you been doing
George during this crazy upside down
time that we've been stuck in for just
about four weeks but it feels like it's
been four years it is you know this has
definitely been different you know
luckily I have a house of this size
garage so we meet my wife and my dad my
mom turned the garage into a gym so has
everything I need you know any other gym
would be s so I don't have to go
anywhere to train I got my spa rec stair
step or rowing machine I got everything
I need in there which is really fun
because you know I'm spending time with
my family and the other thing I've been
doing be my wife has actually been in
the kitchen a little bit more no
whooping things up here and they're
actually made my Easter ham last night
which was pretty fun it's a different
experience of my first time cooking in
Eastern Han yeah I've never cooked in
Easter him how big of a project is that
honestly was a lot easier than I thought
it would be all we did we we covered the
whole thing and like a honey maple glaze
and threw it on my tray just do the sort
of cook for like 30 minutes and it was
dark now I have hands like the next
three weeks so so what yeah what is your
routine when you work out now and how
different isn't than what it would be if
you could go to the facility you know I
wake up you know get a good breakfast in
and then I I luckily through the 49ers
we have we have trainers with that reach
out and they'll put us through workouts
or you know put us through stretching
routines warm-ups and stuff so I get a
nice warm up and then I get a lift in
and after that I try to get some speed
working I got a little bit of a back
yard so I could move a little bit I'm
not running routes full speed right now
wait till the social distancing thing
and so I couldn't catch the ball from CJ
again but overall just trying to do
everything I can just to keep my body in
shape and ready to roll whatever
footballs called back how hard is it to
find the motivation and you haven't
gotten to where we would be in the off
season program yet but it looks like
there's not going to be an off season
program how much harder is it going to
be when you're gonna have to do all of
this on your own without being in a
situation where your teammates are there
and you know that motivation that comes
from being around your friends and being
around your co-workers and even if you
don't like feel like working out you
know you have to go do it when it's just
you how much harder will that be to find
that will and that desire
to basically punch the clock every day
and do what you need to do uh you know
honestly it's pretty easy for me because
like I get paid to play football which
has been my dream since I was a little
kid so you know I wake up and my first
thing is hey I have an opportunity to
get better today I'm not soon to go no
train to play football today and that's
all I look at it and I just wake up I
train I hit it hard you know it's
awesome like my wife's and my dad
actually throw me the football like I
get $100 from the pass of the day so no
I'm just enjoying it you know and I'm
not gonna no I'm not gonna worry about
something that I can't control but I'll
be damned if I let it get the best of me
so I'm gonna go out there I'm a train
now you know like I have guys competing
for my job
no that's what that's what's you know
unprecedent I'm just you know everyone's
trained at their own ways at their own
levels you know so it depends on you
know how seriously you take this
situation if you can hit the ground
running when it all does start back up
but I promise you that I will be
definitely hitting the ground right full
speed for somebody and I love the
attitude and I respect the desire to
always be looking for ways to improve
but I think about everything you've
accomplished so far in your NFL career
and it's hard for me to identify anyways
the George Kittel can't improve what are
you specifically hoping to work on to
take your game to a higher level I mean
there's plenty of things that you can
get better at you know actually my tight
ends coach me my good tape the bad tape
from the season so I've been able to
watch that you know whether it's an
understanding of Koshien hands offense
they don't the plays that I need to be
better on I know whether that's
man-to-man routes or five spot zone or
no hand placement footwork and on the
run game of pass bro you know there's
always something you get better in it
and so you know I'm just taking it one
day at a time I pick something for my
game that I you know I feel like I could
get better at which is you know
everything but so today I might do a
little bit extra footwork in the past
Pro um but that's all I'm doing I'm just
trying to get better one thing at a time
and I feel like if I can just get better
at one little thing every single day but
kind of season starts got quite a head
start on so other guys around the league
what do you watch more George the good
tape or the bad tape oh yeah it's a
mixture of both you know it's fun to
watch the good stuff but no it's damn
frustrating to see all the plays that I
could have been a lot better on it's
definitely like three or four pass grows
throughout the season I want to
headbutt a wall for but no that's what
that's why we play football you know
let's try to get better at it and you
know yeah but like I said you try to
watch them both it's frustrating to
watch the bad but it's also an
opportunity to get better you have the
right attitude for dealing with this
current pandemic we can can only control
what we can control but you know at some
point the events may lead us to a
situation where games are being played
without fans present and you're a guy
who feeds off the fans I saw it at the
playoff game against the Vikings I saw
how you were after the game and and I
know that the presence of the 49ers fans
really really helps you get to that
highest possible level of motivation and
achievement what's that gonna be like if
you go out into that stadium and there's
nobody there that would be weird but if
I can order Seattle or do Orleans
without answer that'll make my job like
you said also yeah I don't listen no
more silent counts nothing like that
that will make my life really easy so
okay I'll play on the road that's that's
fine or no where is that but no
definitely you know the fans is what
makes the game so much fun um no whether
it's winning the game your stadium is
going ballistic or you know you win a
game on the road a crowd goes silent
like both those or things that I know
those are some of the pinnacles of
football for me just hearing that so
it'll be definitely different if that's
you know what happens but no like I said
I'm gonna focus on what I can control
and fighting let's go play football
again I'll be pretty happy
what is the departure of DeForest
Buckner who was traded to the Colts what
does that mean to the 49ers going
forward you know defo is is incredible
you know he's incredible person and an
amazing football player who honestly
don't have bugged me about him is that
he was longer than me and I'm still old
older than he is at just I don't
understand but you know he just he's a
great football player and I'm nothing
more than happy for him he's deserved
every penny that you're going to
Indianapolis will it be tough to replace
a personality a captain and a locker
room guy like him yeah but the thing is
we have such a great Locker and we have
such a great culture that we have guys
that will step up you know now I'm just
looking forward to that like I said I
know nothing but happy for the forest
and you know and making that and
but yeah it'll be difficult but I think
we have the locker to be able to do it
and fill that spot you know it's only
been a couple of months George since a
Super Bowl it feels like it's been so
much longer than that what's the one
memory of that experience it's gonna
stand out for you 50 years from now one
thing I will never forget you know
obviously losing I will say losing Super
Bowl is one of the worst thing that's
ever had in my life
it's hard and you know you gotta you
know move past that you know they miss
but at the same time you know I'm the
nothing but grateful for that
opportunity because my dream as a little
kid was you know the plane is Superbowl
and my other dream was to win a Super
Bowl so I achieved one of those dreams
and you know I'm just trying to get back
there one of my favorite moments though
is just you know running onto the field
I know what the whole team just the fact
that you know trying to soak all in soak
it all end and I was actually planning
the Super Bowl which was know if I told
myself is like a seven or eight year old
but I was gonna play the Super Bowl will
be that kid will be pretty jealous and
so I'm just happy that I got to actually
do that now I just got to get back there
and win it see I wouldn't be able to go
back and watch any of that game or any
that film oh yeah how long did it take
you before you were able to do it um I
watch it I think I watch it a week later
I know my tight end coach hasn't watched
it yet but it is it's like I said it's
it sucks
overall it's one of the no most non fun
things I've been a part of is losing to
rule but I got to play football day in
and day out and still I miss excited to
be back on the field my teammates at
some point you know give us another shot
at you know when it's some more games
getting back to the playoffs and I'm
just looking forward to that opportunity
and I assume part of your leadership of
the organization is going to include
reminding guys what it feels like to be
on the wrong side of that outcome and
the goal now is brick by brick build it
back up get back there and make sure
this time around we win it ya know I
mean it is it's now there are plenty of
plays out there off and Steve in special
teams that we could have played better
you know that's why it's a team sport so
well we just gotta figure that out
figure out a win and I think that's one
thing that our team did such a great job
of last year
figuring out ways to win whether that
was no nine and zero in a rain game in
Washington or you know winning a
shootout in New Orleans or you know deep
in the game against Arizona like it
every every game is different and I
thought our TV grad job of that so we
just continue to figure out how to win
then I think we'll be just fine what do
you think of the playoffs expanding by
one team where there's now an extra
opportunity to get a seat at the table
but if you're the number two seed you
got to play an extra game cool I love it
and I hate at the same time you know I'm
all for you I like I like games I love
the playoffs it's playoffs are some of
the most exciting spot on time in sports
I know that by week four the two seat is
huge I'm all for by weeks I like by
weeks you like it hey George before I
let you go football what are you there
you cut out yeah I'm here okay one thing
before I let you go there was some
chatter that kind of came out of the
blue several weeks back about Tom Brady
grew up in the Bay Area 49ers fan maybe
there was thought he wanted to come back
and play which obviously would mean he'd
be taking Jimmy Garoppolo place what was
your reaction to that talk during that
week or so that it was lingering you
know it is people talking there's
nothing else to talk about it's nothing
that I took seriously you know Jimmy G's
might want to be my quarterback and he's
won one hell of a quarterback we don't
get the Super Bowl without him and so
you know there's no one you know
then I'd replace him with I think what
he's done for this team leadership wise
and on the field it's one of the kind
there's no one else I'd rather be around
to throw me the ball so now I'm just
excited being able to play football
again with Jimmy G and and I know he's
ready to swing that rock again all right
hey George I appreciate some of your
time buddy we wish you all the best
enjoy that ham stay safe and we look
forward to seeing you back on a football
field very soon
hey thank you so much for having me on
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports